can you talk about the opportunities
that are available now that weren't
available to authors previously
yeah i mean i think
right now for writers and other kinds of
artists like almost any sort of creative
person i think there's more opportunity
now than there's ever been i mean if you
really think about it now
i think a lot of people are sort of
used to kind of a traditional way where
they're
putting out their stuff and and
trying to sell it you know and that is
always going to be difficult but in
terms of getting your material into
people's hands i mean as a writer you
know the biggest company on earth amazon
has enabled you to publish your books
with them you know and and
you have a potential audience of
millions of people um wattpad you know
lets you publish little short stories
and things and little snippets of things
and some of those have been optioned and
turned into movies um
youtube tiktok you know all those
you can put out short films you can put
out uh little sketches i mean there's i
think there's constantly stories in the
news about people who have made little
shorts on youtube that end up getting
development deals and things
um
so i mean
the tools are there you know i mean you
just have to
put yourself out there i think that's
the hardest part is like just deciding
i'm gonna put myself out there i mean
honestly like i watch these youtubers
and i am blown away like by how much
work they must put in you know i mean
these you know the successful ones
produce content
like on a daily basis you know a weekly
basis and you know there's
maybe there's implications that are
negative to that but in terms of the
hard work you know that they're doing i
think it's pretty impressive like and so
i think if you're if you really want to
get your stuff out there like there are
so many avenues to do it now like more
than ever in history
oh and sorry also i think i should add
too that on the business side of things
not only can you get your stuff out
there but platforms like facebook you
can run marketing and campaigns and
advertise and actually build audiences
you know i mean the idea 20 years ago
the idea that you could like
build an audience of like 100 000 people
that you know like
similar authors to you and target
advertisements to to a product you have
to those people that would be unheard of
and now
anyone can do that you know you don't
have to be a business or a company like
so i mean again like there's so many
tools that are out there to to
create your content put your content out
there and build an audience for it
what's the most stressful part of being
a professional that you had no clue
until you started
uh i think
we touched on this a little bit earlier
but i think the uh the imposter syndrome
like that that feeling that
you know it's not as good as before it's
not good enough you know i think that is
a uh
i i think i just thought like okay well
if i can get through my first book then
everything else will be easier you know
and uh and actually i heard a lot of
authors say that too like oh the first
book's the hardest and then and in many
ways that's true like in the terms of
like the hours you put into it and
learning the craft and
just what it takes to produce a book
when you've never done it before it is
very difficult but i think what i found
surprisingly hard like i said was kind
of coping with that imposter syndrome
afterwards like i don't maybe i'm not as
good as i think i am or maybe all these
people who like it
that you know they're wrong or they're
not seeing all the problems with it you
know or how or maybe like maybe i just
can't do it again you know like like
that is definitely there and i mean i
think it's ultimately i think it's just
your
brain like psyching yourself out but i
it was a lot more prevalent than i
thought it would be
so when you were writing the first novel
or the novella
maybe there was a little more sense of
wow this is going great before you knew
the response and then once you get a
positive response it sounds like it's
been mostly positive then you start
doubting yourself yeah it's weird right
you would think uh
i think for the first book it's more
like hey can you get this done you know
it's like i've never written a book
before so automatically if i can finish
a novel that's a victory you know and
and i finished it so that's a huge
victory for me like i was super stoked
when i finished it i didn't care if it
was good or not i was just like wow i
finished a book you know
and but like you said the response was
largely positive but and i guess i
thought i never would have or i never
would have thought
that you would feel like worried when
you're getting a largely positive
response but i did find that when i went
on to the second book i'm like oh man
like what if i let these people down you
know like what have all the people who
love the first one and then now they
don't like this one and i let them down
you know like i felt that really
strongly and then again on the third one
and the fourth one and every book i've
ever written like there's that kind of
doubt in the back of your head you know
i think i think it's just
inherent
if you care about what you're doing you
know i think it's inherent in the
creative process
and you just have to learn to kind of
not listen to that voice you know i
think it's always going to be there you
just have to
silence it until you get to the editing
and then that's where i think that can
actually be useful you know where you
can say is this as good as it can be
maybe if i tighten this dialogue maybe i
need to add a scene that explains this
more you know that's where i think the
doubt can help but when you're just
writing i think you need to kind of
ignore that and just
soldier on
and there's so many books on getting to
a certain point but there's not really a
lot of books or yeah there's not a lot
of like
self-help books for the successful
author right like it's like boo hoo
right but uh
yeah it's it's true i i didn't but but
what was funny was all the writers that
said oh the first book is the hardest
later on then they're like oh yeah i
feel that way too like i think
i think a lot of people
either maybe it's a kindness they don't
want to tell you like like they just
want you to think like oh it'll be
easier once you finish this book they
don't want to let you know like oh no
it's just going to get harder and harder
each time well and i'm a broken record
with this one but i'll say it again uh
julia cameron has us that talk about you
know sort of blocked writers or or it's
much easier to
have people like you and gain sympathy
when you're doubting yourself or but
people are fearful of someone who's
confident and doing well because then
they have to look at themselves and say
why am i not there right and you push
people away so it's an interesting thing
where
you don't think you have to worry about
that but then
you know it's much more intimidating to
be someone who's confident and is doing
well
and people like your work than someone
who's well and they're insecure and then
everybody
wants to gravitate to help you yeah it's
a different set of of challenges you
know there but i think it kind of goes
back to like we're saying like it's not
like you're gonna do something and all
of a sudden your whole life is easy
straight you know it's like
certain things might be easier but other
things might be harder
how did your first book hit number one
on amazon so the the way the the sales
kind of went for me was the uh
i released devil's due first and i
didn't even have i didn't really care
how it did you know and it was it was i
was i was giving it away for free anyway
um i did put it up on amazon as well
um
but my real
point of that book was to start building
an audience you know for the next one
and the next so then when i launched
tokyo black which was the first novel it
did well but not you know not like i can
live off of this well but i was happy
because it was my first book and it did
well i mean it certainly made you know
real money that was useful and more
importantly people really liked it um my
the second novel read phoenix that was
the one that really took off like where
um and i couldn't tell you why i mean i
people have asked me you know i think
part of it was that kind of slow process
of building the audience with each book
and i did you know like i said i was
running ads and i'd started started to
learn about marketing and i was using
facebook and
other you know promotion sites for books
and things and i was
i was another you know i wasn't i was
working at the time and another
advantage of working while you're
writing is you do have more capital to
invest you know into what you're doing
and i was able to invest a fair amount
into advertising but that book read
phoenix for whatever reason just
skyrocketed i remember one day i was
post-supervising on a tv show and a
movie simultaneously i was freelance
sometimes i would work multiple jobs and
i you know i left my house and then and
i looked at my sales numbers like oh
they're looking pretty good today and i
kind of figured that would sort of peak
you know or go a little bit higher and
then i got to work and you know an hour
later i looked again and it was like way
higher you know i left and i was like
whoa
and then over the course of that week i
was making more money off the book than
both of those post suping jobs combined
i was like oh wow and that was when i
was like okay i could really do this you
know
so that was sort of the trajectory it
took
what was that a fantastic feeling or was
that scary in the sense that oh is this
going to last
it was i mean
you know i guess because i didn't expect
it to last so i mean i
even i because i hadn't experienced that
yet you know so to me i was like okay
well this must be a crazy day you know
but then the next day it was just as
high and next day was just as high
but i will say that
every author
who goes through those spikes i think
will tell you that i think the more
important thing to realize is eventually
they they don't last you know i mean
it's not sustainable to do that forever
you know i couldn't say why it spiked
the way it did but i did i do think
because i had not gone through
that experience before i kind of thought
oh this is the way it will always be you
know after like a month of it being like
that i was like i guess this is the way
it is but it's not you know i mean the
next book did really well but not that
well you know um
you will have spikes and ups and downs
and good years and bad years so again
that's why i say it's really important
to kind of have a plan and to look at it
long haul
don't when you do have a spike like that
it's great like be happy embrace it but
don't like then build your whole career
plan off that you know because
it's just inevitable that you know
readers come readers go different genres
are hot you know maybe maybe china was
big in the news when i launched that
book or something i don't know but you
know for whatever reason that one
probably to this day i think did the
best out of all of them
red phoenix yeah red phoenix interesting
and i don't think a lot of people are
like oh well do you think that's your
best book and
although it is actually my personal
favorite i don't think that's why
because most people buying it they
haven't read it yet you know so they're
just going off of the reviews and all
the books have good reviews so
i think it's you know i think that i'm
very happy for the success it had it was
it really helped my life out a lot
obviously
um but i think it's more important to
sort of build a consistent you know
career
it's something that you can sustain
did it have more reviews
no um
the books tend to have the way the
reviews tend to go is obviously the
longer books been out the more view it
reviews it has
so i think
tokyo black has the most reviews
of all of them read followed by red
phoenix followed by fire and forget
which is book number three
i the devil's due which is the novella
doesn't have as many but i think that's
because uh because a lot of it gets
given away you know for free so those
people can't review it on amazon because
they didn't buy it